foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast where we have just been singing
Jefferson Airplane to each other but it
is what it is
um it is I feel like you've been given a
pill that makes you larger or smaller 10
feet tall crazy pills yeah I think
that's what it is yeah yes well all
right let's begin at the beginning I am
Dr Brett Weinstein you are Dr Heather
Hein and uh and this guy's not a doctor
at all he is that we know of this is
that we know of this is Tesla named
after the scientist not the car thank
you very much exactly exactly
for those only listening he's a cat he
is a cat he identifies as a cat
identified as you know what she doesn't
because identity is not a thing in
non-humans is that right I think so
really yeah I mean Maybe not maybe once
you have theory of mind you kind of got
identity because if you can identify
someone else and you sort of have a
sense of self but I'm pretty sure cats
no sense of identity no no I actually
think you have um
I I appreciate your conjecture I get of
of what it is is made but uh tell me
that this cat sometimes does not
identify as not having been fed yet even
when he's been fed
that's a state of being a a this is the
this is the distinction between Sarah
and a star in Spanish that is a that is
a different kind of identity that is
only permanent identity
no it
all right but are these other identities
that you're complaining about in in
human space aren't they aren't they
temporary oh no because you're right
because the only people who are not
allowed to transition are people who
have transitioned
right it's temporary until you've done
it once right it's required until you've
done it once I think yep and then
there's no going back no going back
because once you've seen your true self
only the others can tell if you were
actually right well I apologize for
doubting you you had it right I don't
remember what I was right about at this
point you were alleging based on very
little that uh his identity is not
having been fed yet was a temporary
State and therefore not an identity in
the human sense yes
yes yes and uh
yeah if cats could be bored by
conversations he would be bored by this
one right although I will say that we
have now we have done the right thing we
have
um established something important up
front so no matter what else happens
today we have we've made progress oh wow
that's a really low bar uh we're going
to talk today about uh about project
veritas's uh reveals this week around uh
Pfizer broadly right that's that's sort
of it broadly uh but first some top the
hour stuff sure all right we've got uh
Dark Horse
uh that counts channels no now at
Instagram Facebook LinkedIn and on
Twitter uh which are are going to be the
places to go if you are on any of those
platforms to know if we're going to be
live stream or if there's another ghost
episode coming out Etc
uh we follow these live streams at the
live q a some people have already
answered asked questions for this week
you can go to darkhorsesmissions.com to
ask questions we'll be doing that after
this
hour to two hours take a little break
and then come right back here uh in that
break between you could start reading
Hunter gathers Guide to the 21st century
you could if you wanted to uh or uh or
Natural Selections which is where I
write weekly this week I wrote wrote
about 15-minute cities about sort of the
top-down attempts to uh create something
that seems more livable and the problems
with the top-down approach to to uh
Urban Rejuvenation if you're watching on
YouTube know that we are also on on
Odyssey and that's where the chat is
happening not that we can see it but
that's where it's happening and we hear
about it
sometimes uh you can get some stuff that
we think is cool that was that came out
of our heads and the fabulous artists we
work with uh rendered the drawings and
now they're being sold at
darkhorsestore.org uh things like um
Pfizer where the breakthroughs never
stop
yep and lied to a tyrant and lie to a
tyrant and finally we are supported by
you our audience uh so uh we appreciate
you subscribing liking sharing the
videos sharing Clips uh you can find uh
Clips on Dark Horse podcast Clips
Channel both on YouTube and odyssey and
of course uh the audio for the main
broadcast is available everywhere
podcasts or
broadcast podcaster broadcast is that
how you would say that that is how I
would start a poem about it okay
excellent uh you can join our wonderful
Discord community at either of our
patreons and tomorrow at my patreon
we're doing our monthly private q a you
can join us there join Brett's patreon
for access to uh one of his uh monthly
conversations but uh at either of them
you get access to the Discord where
um you can engage in honest
conversations on difficult Topics by
text by voice by video they've got all
sorts of meetups and conversations and
topics and it's really it's it's all
it's all over the place in a really
interesting way and we encourage we
encourage you to go there karaoke and
I'm imagining we can't be far from Rap
Battles on important topics that's
that's bound to happen really
I think so okay I might be tempted to
try that you thought it here first I
thought it yes okay fair enough
and we have sponsors uh we only uh take
sponsorship from companies that make
products or services that we can either
personally vouch for or we um have
someone who can personally vouch for
them for us uh in this case uh we or a
dog we love can personally vouch for all
of these products so without further Ado
here are three ads for this week we've
got Sundays our first sponsor this week
it's a fantastic unique dry dog food
made with your dog's health in mind not
just convenience for the humans our dog
Maddie who's snoring in the corner here
reports that Sundays is out of this
world when Sundays approached us about
about being a sponsor we were dubious
because Maddie's a labrador Labs Elite
basically anything as anyone who's known
a lab knows what possible difference was
she going to show an interest between
her usual kibble a widely available
high-end brand and Sundays well we were
wrong Maddie loves the food that Sundays
makes seriously loves it and is far
better for her than the standard burnt
kibble that comprises most dried dog
food Sundays is the first and only human
grade air dried dog food combining the
nutrition and taste of all natural human
grade foods with the ease of a zero prep
ready to eat formula Sundays is an
amazing way to feed your dog and in a
perch perch
in a pinch a person too right you would
you admitted the first time we read a
Sunday's eye that you would in fact yeah
I and I will tell you that it tastes far
better than other dog food smells that
is about as far as I can go not having
Taste of the others but uh yeah
excellent and you know tastes better
than the other smells is actually
um kind of a high bar yeah I think it's
a let's put it this way
um you're not saying it tastes better
than you can imagine the other stuff
tastes based on how it smells you're
saying it tastes better than the ocean
of smells that seems like a high bar to
me yeah okay
uh Sundays is easy for humans too no
fridge no prep no cleanup no gross wet
dog food smells quite right Sundays is
gently air dried and ready to eat no
artificial binders synthetic additives
or general garbage look at the label
you'll find none of that all of Sunday's
ingredients are easy to pronounce except
for quinoa and healthy for dogs to eat
in a blind taste test Sundays out
performed leading competitors 40 to zero
that sounds like a made-up number but
here's the thing when I have a bowl of
Maddie's previous food ready for her
she's definitely enthusiastic again
she's a lab but when I have a bowl of
Sundaes ready for her it's a whole
different level of enthusiasm she
bounces and Spins and leaps in
anticipation do you want to make your
dog happy with your diet and keep her
healthy try Sundays we've got a special
deal for our listeners receive 35 off
your first order go to sundays4dogs.com
Darkhorse or use code Dark Horse at
checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you're feeding your
dog and if you grew up in the Southern
California area in the 70s 80s 90s then
it's Sunday Sunday super Sundays now in
Fontana
I don't actually know what that was but
that is burned into all of our memories
is it not that's not it's not more used
cars Lots no I think it's like um
car like Parts you might buy to soup up
a car but I don't know but it was
something happening I have no idea yeah
so you just you stopped at the 90s
figuring you were safe there
I I left
yep yep
and that wasn't on Firestone exit South
Gate no that was that was the car no
that was new cars I think oh really yeah
okay okay off in the weeds
off on the weeds
our second sponsor this week is Ned a
CBD company that stands out in a highly
saturated CBD Market Ned was started by
two friends who discovered that their
hyper modern lives were leaving them
feeling quote empty bewildered and
disconnected something about this way of
life just wasn't working they say on
their website so they started net
you can buy CBD products on nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but Ned's
Blends stand out I'm particularly fond
of their de-stress blend Ned's de-stress
blend is a one-to-one formula of CBD and
CBG made from the world's purest full
spectrum hemp and also features a
Botanical infusion of ashwagandha
cardamom and cinnamon CBG
you have something to say
I think everyone who watches weekly
knows that I've always wanted to go to
ashwagandha but go on yes you have yep
CBG is known as the mother of all
cannabinoids I'm not sure who it's who
knows it is that but let's just go go
with it CBG is known as the mother of
all cannabinoids because of how
effective it is at combating anxiety and
stress by inhibiting the reuptake of
Gaba which is the neurotransmitter
responsible for stress regulation this
combination leaves me feeling a bit
easier with whatever comes my way not
because of all of the mother oil
cannabinoids and stuff and such but
because I take it and uh it's easier
it's easier to get on with my focus and
and the things I need to do in the day
many of the CBD companies out there
Source their hemp from industrial farms
in China just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality CBD can have
undesired effects that is USDA certified
organic all of Ned's full spectrum hemp
oil is extracted from USDA certified
organic hemp plants grown by an
independent farmer named Jonathan in
Paonia Colorado I hope for Jonathan's
sake I hope for any other Jonathan's
sake that there's only one in Paonia
Colorado because this Jonathan farmer
Jonathan in Paonia Colorado is a little
bit famous at this point yes I think the
other Brett Weinstein on Twitter can
attest to the problem yeah poor guy
sorry man he handles it well he does
uh also Ned shares third party lab
reports and information about who Farms
their products and their extraction
process on their site these products are
science backed nature-based solutions
that offer an alternative to
prescription and over-the-counter drugs
they are chock full of Premium CBD and a
full spectrum of active cannabinoids
terpenes flavonoids and trichomes Ned's
full spectrum hemp oil nourishes the
body's endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance
if you'd like to give net a try Dark
Horse listeners get 15 off Ned products
with code Darkhorse visit helloneed.com
Darkhorse to get access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d.com slash Dark Horse to
get 15 off we want to thank Ned for
sponsoring the show and offering our
listeners a natural remedy for some of
life's most common health issues all
right I have an idea before I get to my
my ad here yes inflammation is obviously
adaptive but a lot of inflammation is in
places that you don't want it or
triggered by things that shouldn't be
triggering it that's misinformation
see yeah yeah I thought you were going
to say that we're seeing a scourge of
Fat Heads lately and you think that's
inflammation in the wrong place actually
now that you mentioned it I think both
apply it's misinformation we are having
a pandemic of Fat Heads
um right okay our final sponsor this
week uh is House of macadamias for the
macadamic in Exile within all of us
that's right nuts
um that's nuts right that's nuts okay
that's nuts tree nuts which include not
just macadamias but also pecans walnuts
cashews almonds pistachios and more are
delicious and nutritious
they are generally high in fat and low
in carbohydrates which is increasingly
understood to be both satisfying and
good for you but each species of nut is
different and for many of us macadamias
are the best macadamia nuts take a very
long time to grow
however and are rare representing only
one percent of nuts in the marketplace
and because they are both rare and
highly sought after they have the
dubious distinction of being the world's
most expensive nut but between the taste
and health benefits they're worth it
they have fewer carbohydrates than most
other nuts for instance half of what
cashews or pistachios have are
two-thirds of what almonds have what
makes them a perfect snack for breaking
a daily fast and controlling blood
glucose they're also uniquely rich in
omega-7s including especially
Palmetto like
tell metolic acid yeah I don't actually
know what palmitolic acid is well
palmitoleic oh yeah that's a much better
pronunciation I well I I so I actually
did some research in the macadamia nuts
and I this was the first time we read
this ad so it's a couple weeks ago now
but um yeah there's there's actually
growing amount of research into the
Remarkable Health benefits and I think
it's uh yeah Palmetto Legacy
unsaturated fat that has been uh linked
to Natural collagen production fat loss
and heart health see I even footnoted
the address I love that you've got
references and everything refs and
everything yeah I like these nuts we do
yeah and House of macadamia is a company
obsessed with making this amazing food
accessible to everyone they have
partnered with more than 90 farmers in
Africa and now make one-of-a-kind vegan
keto and paleo snacks these include
their dark chocolate dipped macadamias
delicious assortment of bars made with
45 macadamia nuts including salted
caramel and chocolate coconut our
favorites are the Simply Delicious
salted macadamias
with an ambient sea salt
sorry
all right I I somehow I knew that was
coming
yes
in the buffer you you Intuit my dyslexia
so that you could even see the errors I
haven't yet made that's amazing that was
weird it was odd they are amazing and we
love them and think that you will too
our house of academia's Highly
recommends the house of macadamias for
all your macadamic needs looking for
something to nourish and energize you
while in the pursuit of Truth or the
next Summit go to
www.houseofmacademias.com and use the
code Darkhorse for a 20 discount on your
first order
all right all right
did it did it all right
um
all right well we are gonna talk about a
number of things this week around
project Veritas and Pfizer and
uh what what all that means we're not
gonna so for for we're not going to show
the videos that were released because
YouTube struck uh project veritas's
Channel and removed the first video but
we will talk about it for those of you
who don't yet know but we're not going
to start there we're going to start with
something that ends up feeling a little
bit related uh but is uh but we may feel
orthogonal at first after you yeah
orthogonal good one thank you that is a
seven dollar word if I recall correctly
with inflation over that uh no it's like
a forty dollar work now thank you um
because it's made with eggs but
um all right first thing we're going to
start with uh only pasture dags for us
from now on
only pastured eggs for right yeah the
domestication of everything including
the food that the domesticated animals
that we eat or that produce the food
that we eat eats is causing a health
Scourge and that is not what we're
talking about today but I just thought
since you mentioned eggs no it's good in
fact I think we should just get all
these sides done now are there any other
asides that we could see coming that's
not the way with the sides I guess it
isn't yeah all right so later on there
may be a side of sides
um we will have with the main course
which begins with Scott Adams cracker
me you're not the first person to level
that accusation and no one's ever found
anything to suggest that it's accurate
so you are a white guy
I have the prerequisite okay okay it
doesn't make me a cracker man we swear
we're sober yeah let's um all right
let's get Let's Get Serious
Scott Adams has turned the world
somewhat upside down with at first his
acknowledgment that those of us who had
resisted this uh so-called vaccine
campaign had actually turned out to be
right and that he had in fact been wrong
and that seemed like a generous
forthright proper admission of having
changed his position
he Then followed it up with a slew of
like I don't know it's like 60 000
tweets at this point that are confusing
and seemed to muddy the waters and the
gist of at least many of these follow-on
tweets is that although he acknowledges
that he got it wrong and that those of
us who uh resisted some other people
didn't get it wrong some other people
didn't get it wrong his point is it was
a coin flip so you could either go with
the official narrative or you could
resist the official narrative and
um some people resisted and they turned
out to be right but there was no method
to figuring out what the truth was
because the information stream is so
polluted
one interpretation of which is
I didn't have a method therefore no
method can exist
yes and you know
I must say
Scott is an interesting character and I
like a good deal of what he does the way
he prods people is I think quite useful
often and there is an aspect to this
prodding that I think is positive but
there's also a weird
feature of it where it seems to be that
he is resistant to the idea that there
might even be a method and his basic
point is well then teach it to me right
and the answer is there is a method
it's not teachable that way
um and go ahead well I guess you know as
I said in the one response that I gave
to him online
um
you know it's
it can't be a static strategy right like
you can't you can't that the teach it to
me seems to be if it's in good faith at
all which of course many people are
convinced it's not but seems Seems to
imagine a just tell me the thing and
then I'll do that thing next time tell
me the tell me the people and I'll just
do what they did next time and you know
this is this is not the way complex
systems works and frankly the thing I
said to you was
I really would have expected that the
the genius mind behind Dilbert
would understand that because the
recognition of the gaming of office
politics at every level would seem to be
easily generalizable too like okay
static strategies and uh and you know
people who come at you with patently
easily falsifiable claims
uh don't aren't the things that you
should be relying on right like that
that would that would seem to have been
something I would have imagined that
would be something that would be in
Scott Adams had given given he would be
native to him yeah okay so a I will say
I was gratified to see the number of
people who said what about Brett and
Heather what about Dark Horse right
because frankly people who are uh long
time listeners have seen something that
is not an easily described method but
it's clearly methodological in its own
way and they've also watched it be
Vindicated on issue after issue so there
is a question about you know if you take
um Scott's claim that this is coin
flipping it is not impossible that you
could flip
8 or 10 heads in a row but it is
exceedingly unlikely and I would also
point out all right Tom stop replaying
right the Tom stoppard uh rosencrant
Cranston segment
um is
quite the right uh model because
basically the playwright takes the
liberty of writing and in probably long
string of coin flips which is then what
the actors deliver and the actors are
there for in a position to detect that
they are in a play or something is off
because it's so unlikely but because
it's no less likely than any other
sequence
um you know anyway there's lots of
philosophical uh drilling down on that
question to be done but here's the
here's the thing
Scott you have delivered a hypothesis
it is a perfectly valid hypothesis that
everybody who got it right is guessing
that they are simply choosing between
binary Alternatives and some people will
be improbably lucky
however Scott
that hypothesis makes a clear prediction
okay if you take somebody who has had an
improbably long sequence of correct
guesses in your coin flip Universe they
will going forward have no more success
at being accurate than anyone else
because there's nothing about having
been right that predisposes you to be
right in that coin flipping if random
then random then random if random then
random like it that's exactly exactly
what it is so Scott you've signed
yourself up for that now the
um the issue then is if we are claiming
that there is something that is not
exactly a method it is not something
that we can you know let's take an
example of what it means that it's not
exactly a method all right if if you saw
an amazing feat of archery and they're
indeed some favorites of mine I'm now
forgetting the name of the the fella who
me too but anyway there's some people
who demonstrate some incredible archery
skill and you know you could some of it
could be faked a little bit like you
know throwing a bottle uh top and not a
bottle top a can flip top piece into the
air and shooting an arrow through it you
could shoot a million arrows and then
film the one that did it but if the guy
throws one up in the air shoots it
throws another one up in the air and
shoots it that you can't without an edit
right and so the point is how many 100
million shots would you have to do in
order to get lucky twice in a row like
that and there's actually a great
Channel I forget what it is but there's
a Channel of trick shots where you know
somebody will set up a
you know shot glasses sitting on a
turntable and you know they're bouncing
pennies off of something and it will go
in and it's done they obviously are
using the method of shooting a million
times not a million but that's an
exaggeration but they're shooting a huge
number of times and they film the ones
that work and then they cheer because
you know they they're bored out of their
minds trying to get these things to
happen and that's archery as well no
it's not our treats it's a million
different trick shots it's pretty cool
stuff but anyway the point here is if I
say oh this person that does these
amazing archery trick shots has a method
right
and you say method
what is that method show me
right well let me handle the message
right let me in on the method so I can
do those things well
no it's not that kind of a method is
there a method running inside the head
of a fantastic Archer who can do amazing
things of course right or somebody who
does trick shots in pool whatever it
might be but the point is that method is
not a an explicit method necessarily and
B it is not simple it's a hard thing to
learn well and it's also very
feels very precarious
if you're accustomed to the landscape in
which certainty is necessary
it feels very precarious at first to
learn and you know we we had this
experience in our classrooms quarter
after quarter year after year and you
know and in grad school before that but
you know welcoming students into a
classroom saying we're going to learn
how to think evolutionarily here and
um very often we're not going to know
and we're going to we're going to sit
there in the not knowing and yes that
sounds you know philosophical and
vaguely Buddhist or something but you
know it it is there you know there's a
reason that many Traditions converge on
this you know actually the uncertainty
and the spending the time trying to
figure out what the question is and and
not having come to a conclusion so that
you can be open to the various sources
of information that are coming at you is
is part of what is necessary and you
can't just hear that and say okay I'll
do that then
because you can try and you should try
and you will get better at it over time
but you won't be as good at it the first
time you do that as you are the
hundredth time it just won't be yep
um so I thought what we should do is we
should actually describe a few things
that have gone into what you and I are
doing that you could describe as
methodological and
um you know we could move on from there
but I think the first thing for somebody
like Scott who I assume is genuinely
curious about how you would improve your
chances in a garbage in information
landscape right and a couple of things
that are relevant are one recognizing
that the garbagey nation nature of the
information is in some sense reliable
because there are processes that have
turned our truth-seeking mechanisms into
uh paradoxes right so
basically the answer is a stuck field is
easy to beat right a field that becomes
overly concerned about uh profitability
or about reaching a conclusion that is
politically uh viable and understood to
be morally good those fields are going
to be hobbled in their own truth seeking
and so the point is you're not beating
right a world full of experts who are
doing their best and screwing it up
you're dealing a world through you're
dealing with a world full of experts who
are compromised by you know careerism
for example you know careerism exists as
Heather points out you're the Dilbert
guy right imagine that what goes on in
offices goes on with fancier jargon and
bigger better equipment in Laboratories
in universities right that's what's
going on you've got careerism
credentialism uh territoriality all of
these things compromise these fields and
if you don't have obligations to those
structures you are actually free to do
something that they can't do
um so one thing I I'm just going to
repeat that point which is that many
people outside of science even if they
can see the inanity which sometimes
verges into Insanity in their particular
domain be it office culture or
entertainment or the law or government
or whatever it is
somehow assume that what happens in
science often now people don't assume
what happens in Academia is is pure
because you know that that you know the
the
I don't even know what like something's
been torn off like we can all see this
now right but people still imagine that
well if you if you call it science the
people who went into science must have
done so for only the purest reasons uh
there must only be the most honorable
and upstanding moral players in science
and therefore if it comes at you under
the imprimatur of science it it must be
sciency and you know honestly the last
three years
um have been the you know repeated
constant proof that that's not the case
but from within science since the early
90s when we early mid 90s when we
started in grad school and even in
undergrad when we were when we were
working with some of the you know best
scientists in the world
uh it was clear that
um science is no different right that
there are there are you know brilliant
players and there are ridiculous players
and there are naive ones and non-naive
ones and you know the entire gamut of
Human Experience is represented there as
well as of course it would be
and uh of course you would if you are in
the world and you see ah what has
replaced frankly religion as the thing
that everyone looks up to and doesn't
question oh it's science well all I have
to do is get myself some glassware and a
lab coat and maybe I'll have to get that
fancy degree but then then I'm
unquestionable and so you know it's
we've been doing this for decades but in
part what we're what we've been doing is
saying you know we've got lots of
scientists in our audience but for the
people who don't think of themselves as
scientists saying not only can you but
you must you know question the stuff
when it comes at you when it's dressed
up as science because of course that's
going to be a thing that they do when
they're not actually revealing science
to you yeah or another way to say it is
questioning the science is how you do
science right yes that is much much
tighter it's much it's much tighter but
um so anyway I mean at one level
You've Got A system that if even from
the outside you can see it's riddled
with perverse incentives right you can
see that the way funding is done is
going to result in people who play the
game out competing people who do the job
exquisitely well but don't play the game
right that's true and it's true at a
level you probably can't imagine if
you've not been inside of a university
setting but all right so you've got a
bunch of fields that are uh
underperforming is a severe
understatement you've got a bunch of
fields that have gotten themselves stuck
in a ditch for no reason and the
question is what can you do outside of
those fields now
you and I first of all they're just a
bunch of things that belong on the table
here one of them is how did we get it
right
well we didn't get it right that's not
what happened what happened was we
started with our best understanding of
what was taking place which was clearly
wrong in some ways and we moved in the
direction of getting writer and writer
right that's the way it's actually done
it's not a method for being right there
is no method for being right there's a
there's a method for taking your
understanding and upgrading it based on
information and I will say one of the
most important features of this
environment
figuring out how not to process
everything
if you feel responsible for processing
every fact relevant to a question that
you are interested in you will end up
processing some facts that aren't facts
that are simply untrue and if your point
is what we do in science is we reconcile
all of the facts so that they fit
together in a model but a third of your
facts aren't facts at all they're the
result of corruption or error or
something like that then your model will
not work it will you know and it's
anti-scientific to say well but it's a
fact therefore it must work like okay
you have you have to keep going back
down the decision tree the Assumption
tree and saying which of the things that
I know to be true aren't in fact true
that is that is how you reconcile
irreconcilable facts yep you you figure
out which of them isn't in fact a fact
which of them isn't in fact a fact and
there are you know there are there are
I don't want to say tricks but there are
ways to spot them right so for example
if your model is getting better and
better how would you know it's getting
better and better because it gets more
and more predictive and then it stops
doing that well that suggests that you
picked up something that you thought was
a fact that wasn't all right and so the
ability to back your model off and say
when did it stop improving and what
happened at that place and then looking
at the thing that you picked up and you
say why why did I think that that was
one of the ones I could rely on so
anyway it's it's things like this what
was the source of that and do I have any
other fact facts from that source and
how reliable are they and so you know
you it it it's many it's many tentacled
in terms of like how you assess both you
know starting with as few assumptions as
possible being absolutely sure of them
it's sort of like the the axiomatic
level and adding facts sometimes
liberally but if you do being aware that
uh some of them may turn out to be
something that you have to reverse and
try not to build too much on the things
that you haven't fully fully vetted
right and and we don't it's those last
three years
we didn't like no one knew for you know
in many moments like what landscape are
we even in what are we actually even
trying to figure out yeah right and uh
and the early days as we talked about
here on Dark Horse and like you know
almost three years ago like oh my God
it's the Wild West in a good way out
there with regard to Scientific
publishing all of those um pre-print
servers that were just churning out
papers without the peers you know the
peer review process which is supposed to
be this great thing that's actually
become a Scourge on science without the
peer review process getting in the way
and the delays associated with it
suddenly there was all of this often
really high quality science available
right but the other thing about it was
because it was happening so quickly that
we were all driven to the preprint
servers rather than the so-called
peer-reviewed literature what that meant
was you didn't need to explain to
anybody why you were you were processing
this paper and not that one the
expectation is not that you're going to
process the entire you know group of
unpublished results some of them are
garbage and won't make it right and they
were coming out I mean like just so so
fast right and so the point is look
this is the problem
it is the selectivity right where you
decide hey that result actually would
make a lot of sense I think that one
might be valid now I'm going to go look
at the method and see whether it
actually says what I think it says and
if it does say what I think it says here
are the cascading consequences of it
logically and then if it turns out that
result is bad you have to have kept
track of what you stacked on it so that
you remember to reverse those things
and there's there's something critical
and slightly obscure in what you just
said with regard to the selectivity uh
that it is it is often considered a
given that in literature review uh in
attested and assessing uh you know what
is known in a field before uh perhaps
you embark on testing a hypothesis of
your own that you do a thorough
literature review right like you're
supposed to know everything that anyone
has ever thought at least if they've
thought it and published it on a topic
and for some topics and uh under you
know more slow moving times that is
um in in many ways an honorable approach
although you know we used to in our
classrooms argue that it might be better
to go in especially if you're an
undergraduate doing a research project
go in without knowing what other people
have thought and then afterwards after
you have figured out after you have
designed your experiment and taken the
data and analyzed it and now know what
you think you know know what you think
you found then go and see what other
people have thought like that's that
actually helps you hone your own
understanding of the universe better but
that aside
one thing that uh is being gamed now is
this uh idea that you aren't really
allowed to speak on a topic until you
know everything there is to say about it
so this is how we get Silo this is how
Specialists become the only people who
are allowed to speak on a particular
topic but what do you do
when is it public health is it virology
is it vaccinology is it Immunology is it
in fact evolutionary biology which of
course is at the at the interface
between all of those because
evolutionary biology has a lot of
specific parts to it you know there are
phylogenic systematists for instance and
and within that there are Cletus and
there are you know maximum
likelihoodists
evolution of biology writ large is the
interface of all of these evolved
complex systems coming together and
frankly it gives you the bigger view
down than if you are just narrowly going
like well if it's not about viruses I
don't know anything about it right so
that you know that that is part of what
it is to be thinking evolutionarily is
to have the broader view yeah that was
one of the things uh on my list of
primary contributors is that you know
almost everybody in almost every
discipline is over specialized because
competition which is the thing that is
being used to drive this forward
competition which is unfortunately not
so much about being right anymore it's
about publication and other proxies for
being right which turn out to be pretty
bad but that competition has created an
environment in which people become the
experts on something so narrow that it
doesn't apply to anything else and that
is a recipe for becoming a fool with an
advanced degree so evolutionary biology
as you said is the generalist Paradigm
that allows you without being a
specialist to understand how vaccinology
and Immunology uh integrate how and how
epidemiology and vaccinology and
epidemiology integrate for example so in
any case you and I have a toolkit right
it's not specialist in any of these
domains but it is capable of dealing
with all of them that was one of the
things that we heavily leveraged the
other thing is Central to what we said
in our book about how you navigate novel
problems right what we say in the book
about novel problems is we use the
moniker campfire campfire is how human
beings bootstrap solutions to problems
they don't already have and they do it
by talking to each other the idea is the
campfire happens in the evening when
you're not busy looking for roots and
tubers or huntable animals navigating
phone trees navigating wait
I'd rather be hunting for roots and
Timbers but that raises for me the image
of hunter-gatherers
in the Serengeti and the occasional
phone tree
um from where they presumably get their
phones but
um anyway we have digressed sorry
um but anyway the point is evolution is
a generalist uh toolkit it allows you to
process these things campfire is the
process of more than one individual
pooling what they know pooling their
different skill sets individuals don't
tend to have the identical skill set you
and I are both evolutionary biologists
but we take very different approaches to
it but the point is and coming at each
other and saying oh I think this like I
don't I don't get it what do you think
right I think this oh oh you think that
no you still don't have it oh I think
this oh I see what you think now here's
why I think you're wrong and you know
and you know doing that with you know
with love if you have it or at least
some affection and recognition that the
person that you're talking to is another
human being
as opposed to the way that argument and
conversation in quotes tends to happen
in you know on social media and in sort
of cartoonish fashion these days uh
which is well if you disagree you must
be evil or if you disagree you must not
be human right and you know know what
we're doing by disagreeing like that
that's the love like that is the sign
that you actually care about the other
person as opposed to saying oh I'm just
it's too much work I'm just not gonna
I'm not gonna do it like that that's
actually giving up and that's a sign of
disrespect
absolutely and I'll say two more things
before we move down the road here a
piece one is the ability to filter out
stuff you don't want to process is
essential or don't think that you should
process because you have doubts about it
even though it will result in you
throwing out things that are true right
the point is you want to buy us in that
direction including garbage in your
model is much worse than failing to
include something true or being delayed
and waiting to include it right yes yes
so I preference more or less for type 2
error over type one
um
but the problem is an actor who is
perversely incentivized and liberated to
pick and choose what they process will
of course engage in confirmation bias
somebody who has written a book on a
premise that is incorrect right that
person is much harder to back off that
premise because they now have a lot
riding on it it will be embarrassing and
it's hard to unpublish a book so or I
mean even even more so built a career on
so you know the late stage
late late career stage academics uh who
have have built everything on something
uh very rarely say you know what not so
much right there are a couple of famous
examples which I'm forgetting at the
moment but it is it is stunning when you
see these sort of late late career
reversals uh in which the person says
well okay you know glad I know and that
like that maybe maybe that too yeah I've
been I've been
in other contexts recently I've been
reminded of this I'm glad I know
Revelation like well that sucked now you
know now I saw how many people weren't
courageous or weren't telling the truth
or that the thing that I believed and
built those other stuff on was wrong
well
glad I know okay sunk cost is sunk costs
and let's move forward now yep and I
will point out you and I have a book out
that is not yet available in soft cover
right that's a pretty new book
um we have acknowledged a couple things
in it that we believe to be accurate
when we wrote it that we have come to a
different understanding and even that
short period of time so the point is
that commitment to what's actually true
so I'm thinking specifically of what we
said about supplementation
uh and yes well although I will so let's
let's just since you brought it up right
um I stand by the idea that we we should
prefer
to get our our nutrients um from our
from our diet or in the case of vitamin
D from the Sun me too uh but especially
with regard to vitamin D which is the
one that we called out by name in the
book
um the uh the number of people living in
high latitudes uh mostly inside mostly
covered in clothes when they're outside
and actually live at a latitude above
which
um for some of the year they literally
cannot synthesize vitamin D from the sun
vitamin D supplementation seems um to be
you know quite quite the opposite of
what we argued in in the book like an
actual um a true good that actually
enhances immune function and it's
contributing to People's Health right
now I will say that this is again a
place where the model keeps getting more
refined right there are caveats about
this there are apparently multiple kinds
of vitamin D and so depending upon what
you measure you'll you'll see different
patterns but uh my current model which I
think you and I share is sunlight is by
far the best way to generate or to
acquire vitamin D through this
photosynthetic process
and that supplementation while it is
important is much less effective it is
much better for driving up levels in the
blood to prevent Vitamin D from being
lost right so the
um it's confusing the way you said it I
think it's better supplementation is
better for maintaining levels as opposed
to for driving up levels that's what I
mean so the basic point is make vitamin
D while the sun shines as we said and
that means not just hey I'm out in the
sun I'm making vitamin D well you're
making vitamin D on your face and maybe
your arms but you're probably wearing
long pants or whatever so make as much
vitamin D to get naked as close to it as
you can while your app or whatever
you're using tells you the sun is high
enough in the sky during a right part of
the year that you can actually make
vitamin D and then part of the planet on
the right yeah these things have to
align the fact that the sun is shining
isn't enough but make as much vitamin D
as you can so that you're not deficient
and then dramatically slow the rate at
which you lose the vitamin D and become
deficient with supplementation something
like that so anyway this is a and you
know that model I'm not telling you
that's the final state I'm telling you
that having refined the model three or
four times that's the current state so
all right you raised that as you know
even our book which just came out a year
and a half ago
um has some things in it that uh we are
our positions have evolved right right
vitamin D being one and I would say
um we said something absolutely
unequivocal in the book about vaccines
and the miraculous contribution they
have made to human health which I still
believe but I would certainly put a
caveat in there now and say there are
different vaccine Technologies and that
um that there the value of this
technique has to now be
re-uh investigated with respect to is
there a level of vaccination against too
many pathogens simultaneously that
causes it not to be good is there a
protocol that should be deployed in
which you are told that you should avoid
certain antigens within a certain period
of time after you've been vaccinated or
adjuvant's just simply a dead end to
begin with okay but it's not a book
about vaccines right it's mostly not a
book about health and medicine right
although there's a chapter in there two
chapters on health and Medicine uh and
what we say specifically is the three
great successes of Western medicine are
surgery antibiotics and vaccines and we
also say all of them can be used in
times and contexts when they should not
be used we did not go into I think I
think we tell one story about the Cipro
the um whatever that class of
antibiotics is that's got a long
phloxamine something
that probably contributed to my
rupturing my achilles tendon many years
after we'd both been on Cipro a lot so
we do tell one specific antibiotic story
uh but uh you know it's not it's not a
book that explores all of the places
where things are gotten right and things
have gotten wrong and unlike vitamin D
the information was out there and
available and we didn't have it whereas
uh largely what has happened since uh
you know since the book went out of our
hands and we had no more ability to
change it uh has has been most of the
reveal of what you know like an update
based on things that have happened since
publication is different than an update
based on actually we kind of got this
wrong and we had the ability to know
better which and I think I think this is
two different situations I agree
I think I think we're deep in the weeds
but the basic point was
things like having built a career having
written a book make it hard to update a
model because you have now a a risk of
embarrassment and a commitment to
updating these models is essential in
fact you probably shouldn't write the
book If you can't update the model later
if the book turns out to be in some way
imprecise or inaccurate
um all right so
generalist toolkit active discussion
between people who don't feel the
obligation to validate what the other
person is saying but understand that
proper science is done when you push
each other around and that that's not
personal right that's how we were both
trained that's how the cultures of the
Laboratories in which we learned to
think evolutionarily that's how it went
um and you know that's that's how you
learn the method it's not the kind of
thing Scott that you can
um you know see on a piece of paper and
know it and not be wrong again that's
not going to work
um yeah you can't
you can't do anything to guarantee
you'll never be wrong again unless you
never make any claims again right so all
right
um
scientific method generalist toolkit
campfire discussions and don't expect to
be right expect to get more right over
time based on processing information
that's actually
likely enough to be correct or close to
correct that processing it makes you
smarter rather than Dumber
um so anyway that's we can maybe leave
this there unless there's something you
want to add to it no it's good
all right I I hope people figure this
out though because it would be great you
know there are some
uh
oh I guess one other thing I would add
there are people that we talk to
when we're not talking to each other
that contribute that does happen that's
not what I'm saying yeah when we do not
happen to be in conversation with each
other at that moment there are other
people that we interact with
um that's so true
there are people that one comes to trust
based on the fact that they seem to be
doing something parallel to what you and
I are describing that we do here right
figuring out who to pay attention to
when somebody says actually this is a
really interesting result giving it an
extra boost because that person tends to
have a really good nose for results that
turn out to be right and important right
that's a very useful thing
um so I should probably point to a few
of these people uh Chris Martinson right
has been
just so spot on so many times it's
incredible if you don't follow Chris you
should follow him so we'll link his like
YouTube channel the show notes yep I
would say I have more recently become
aware of Brett Swanson whose substack we
have talked about
um but he does some very good
explorations of claims where people make
a claim that something's is uh
seen in the data and he'll say well is
it so for example his sub stack on the
question of were three million people
saved by the vaccine the coveted vaccine
campaign was a slam dunk
um
uh jumie Kim does deep Dives on a
biological topics where she's very
careful to
process them in a way that you can just
see what the evidence actually for and
against particular claims is it's very
uninflected with ideology or emotion
it's just here's what a highly competent
person sees when they use their tools to
explore a question
Alex marinos is has been excellent he's
not a biologist by training he does have
an advanced degree I guess in computer
science but there's many many more but I
think listening for everyone is is a
mistake trying to be exhaustive is going
to be unfair to the people we forget
that's certainly true I'll just finish
by saying
that Alex has approached questions that
impact us
um
like well does Ivermectin work right and
he has explored those and he's delved
deep into these large-scale randomized
controlled trials that are claimed to
prove that it doesn't and it's amazing
what's in there you find fraud
and you find that actually in spite of
the fraud the pattern that it does work
is present and it's obscured by the way
they wrote it up
um so it's an amazing thing but figuring
out who to listen to who tends to have a
good hit rate is key and
um I guess all of those people show
their work and which is what we do right
all right so
um
we're we're gonna segue now to talking
about uh project veritas's uh
Revelations this week
uh for those uh who are listening later
in time when it's not so present or if
you have just not watched the video uh
we'll link to the rumble video
um but as I said at the top of the hour
so project Veritas is an organization
started
10 15 years ago something like this
maybe basically to do undercover
investigative reporting um
and
they had someone apparently go on a date
this week with a guy named Jordan
Tristan Walker who's an MD and the
director worldwide r d strategic
operations and mRNA scientific planning
at Pfizer
had that title since 2021 uh Walker has
and so the the project Veritas guy who
is not seen on camera you can hear him
is pretending to be on a date with
Walker
and basically asking him open-ended and
leading questions about what is
happening uh at Pfizer so just a few
more things about Walker before we do
some some quotes and talk about what we
what we think is going on here uh Walker
was a consultant at BCG that's the
Boston Consulting Group
um before uh he was the worldwide r d
strategic operations and mRNA scientific
planning director at Pfizer which is
itself interesting uh you know he's he's
a consultant guy which is consistent
with something he says in the second
video that project Veritas releases
um when he's sort of gone into
scared and trying to fix the problem
he's just created for himself and for
everyone mode
um and then he got his medical degree it
looks like in in 2018. so you know he
does have a medical background but it
seems like mostly he's been doing
consulting and sort of strategic
planning for for Pfizer
so um like I said YouTube removed their
video for a guess what violation of
their Community guidelines we've been
there without any more specificity at
least that has been shared uh with us
publicly
um but the video is still up on Rumble
so uh you basically have a uh there must
be a hidden camera in like the guy's
glasses or something uh showing uh
Walker again the the consultant medical
doctor advisor saying for instance quote
you know how the virus keeps mutating
one of the things we're exploring is why
don't we just mutate it ourselves so we
could preemptively develop new vaccines
so this would seem to imply
that Pfizer would be mutating viruses
and then releasing them into the world
so that their newly developed vaccines
would then be effective
but
um
that seems even too far for Pfizer
well
it I have to say I was alarmed when I
saw this interaction because
what he says they are doing
does not make sense I'm not going to
just share the rest of the quotes though
before you respond why don't you share
the rest of the questions
um
as you can imagine Walker continues no
one wants to be having a Pharma company
mutating viruses
the anonymous state says sophizer is
ultimately thinking about mutating covid
Locker well no no well that's not what
we say to the public no it was a thought
that came up in a meeting and we were
like why do we not it was like we're
going to consider that with more
discussions
then Walker says a little later the way
it would work is we'd put this virus in
these monkeys and we successfully caused
them to keep infecting each other and we
collect I'm actually going to gray out
the extra words here to make it easier
to hear what he's saying and we collect
samples from them and then the ones that
are more infectious we'll put them in
another monkey and then just constantly
actively mutate it
so yeah
I don't know if you want to hear all the
things like well let's let's stop there
this is this is the thing that threw me
yeah okay so that that is serial
passaging is what he's talking about
he's talking about serial passaging in
monkeys to make the virus more
infectious
now this
does not add up as stated and so there's
a question this guy appears to be we can
debate how high level he is but he does
appear to be at the top of some sort of
uh directorate of mRNA so all right he's
involved in strategy but he's deeply
inside of Pfizer dealing with the MRNA
technology telling us that they are
doing serial passaging with the virus
but it is not obvious why Pfizer would
want to do that so I want to make the
biology a little bit clearer not only
doesn't it is is it clear Wi-Fi's or
want to do that
it's not like
it's not clear Wi-Fi's would want that
result
and it's and it's really not clear I
mean it's actually clear that that
approach to getting that result would
not Garner that result well that's not
the science is just wrong well as stated
I think it's nonsense it seems to be an
actual nonsense yeah and the reason that
I say that is let's compare to what was
done we think in Wuhan okay in Wuhan you
had a viral ancestor taken from a bat
cave probably a mine
um the viral ancestor
we are extrapolating a little bit from a
complex story some of you will know but
that Viral ancestor was weakly capable
of infecting humans but not capable of
jumping between them
that ancestor brought into the lab in
Wuhan we think was then probably
serially passaged through
human Airway tissue that sells an in
vitro human Airway tissue humanized mice
these are mice that have been
molecularly altered so that they
function from the virus's perspective as
a human background
and ferrets those are the three likely
candidates
now
in that case you're taking a bat adapted
virus and then you are exposing it to
environments that will enhance its
function relative to human infectivity
just let's say also ferrets for reasons
that I don't
must be interesting I don't know what
the explanation is are immunologically
very similar to humans and actually more
similar than most monkeys it's not
immunologically it's the ace2 receptor
oh it's just the ac2 receptor right and
with regard to monkeys uh do are they
all I mean he almost has monkeys it's a
good question presently not looking at
tamarinds but for our purposes it
doesn't matter okay because the point is
you've got a virus that's not adapted to
humans at all and then you expose it to
three selective environments that lead
in the human Direction ferrets because
the ace2 receptor which this virus in
particular utilizes
um is a match right you've got human
Airway tissue which is human and you've
got humanized mice which have been made
more human-like for this purpose so in
that case you take something that is
remote that would need an intermediate
host remember we've never found the
intermediate host in the wild that would
explain how this virus got from bats to
people right so what was the
intermediate host it was the laboratory
with these three environments right
okay now the virus has spread around the
world billions of people have been
infected right this is now a very well
adapted virus to people if you take it
to monkeys it will evolve away from
Human adaptation maybe not very far
because maybe monkeys are close enough
but it's not positive from the point of
view of enhancing its infectivity of
humans so
it's like it's like virulence or
infectivity is a abstraction and once
infectious you know infectivity would
apply equally to anything that you're
talking about it's like we we know and
certainly the people who really know
what's going on at Pfizer know this that
you know infectious high infectivity in
a human does not mean high infectivity
in a
cockatoo right right so
you could produce Maybe
in fact I don't think it would work even
well you could produce a variant right
or maybe a few variants through this
experiment in a small number of monkeys
but those wouldn't be useful variants
from the point of view of predicting
what the virus is going to do in people
which is why he says they're doing it
right they want to know what it's going
to do beforehand so they can get ahead
on vaccines
but that won't happen from this
experiment as he described it which
raises the question of what exactly is
going on here and I think there are
really three
broad possibilities
one is this guy's just shooting the
on a date and he's making stuff up maybe
Loosely based on something but this is
about the date and not about
uh biology
that it's nuts enough that it doesn't
mean anything
second possibility which is what he
basically what he claims in his
incoherent way when he is it is revealed
that it wasn't a date right I'm a liar
right right so we will come back to that
um the second possibility is that
um
there is a
absolutely monstrous explanation for
what he's talking about that we can
infer from what he said but I'll come
back to that the third possibility is
that he's not really very good at the
biology at all and that he is reporting
something real but he doesn't get it
enough to report it properly and that
something is missing from what he said
well and but also in that possibility is
he wasn't a meeting he was in several
meetings but he refers to a meeting that
day you know the day of the date in
which
they were spitballing
right that you know the the Pfizer execs
in the room with him we're talking about
what they might do and
you know he says it was a thought that
came up in a meeting and we were like
why do we not it's like well we're going
to consider that with more discussions
that you know that Framing and it's you
know we're so many levels deep here it's
really hard to know but that framing
does sound like someone who given that
what he says is fairly incoherent
that he heard some real stuff it's going
to impress a date he you know heard
conversation that uh was just in the
sort of Nay scent well let's talk about
this and know those conversations that
people advisor never want to get out
there of course because they're terrible
but given that what he reports on this
project Veritas video doesn't make
scientific sense that does seem like it
is a real possibility a real possibility
now there's of course more to the story
because Pfizer has finally responded
um but let's just let's just fill in the
Monstrous but unlikely possibility yeah
okay the Monstrous but unlikely
possibility is that if you
changed this virus in the lab by letting
selection modify it in monkeys
and then it were released
and you know you knew that that was now
going to be uh spreading and you had
your vaccine ready that could be
um
a very effective
but absolutely diabolical mechanism for
making your products uh necessary yep
right now I don't really put such a plan
past Pfizer after all these people have
been eager to vaccinate kids who aren't
threatened by covid with a vaccine that
does threaten them that doesn't seem to
faze them so I don't really think
there's any moral obstacle to such a
plan but I don't think the people at
Pfizer may be a lot of things but
they're not dumb
and the thing is if Pfizer was caught
making new viruses that they would then
have to release into the world
then that is going to make these people
you know
um it's going to put them on a very
short list of extremely evil people from
history and they don't have any reason
to do it they have a very good business
model it's immoral for sure but it's
much safer than running that kind of
risk so I just don't see them pulling
that kind of shenanigans because it's
not in their interest to do it right
they've gamed The Regulators they don't
have to do this the game The Regulators
they've got the government mandating
their product and buying it right this
is like the you know this is the this is
the next level of organized crime so
that means that's but to me that's the
Crux
it would be
extraordinarily evil obviously uh but it
would also be unnecessary right business
level unnecessary and very very risky
right yeah very risky so I don't think
that that's what he's telling us
it just doesn't add up that will take a
lot of convincing to believe that that's
what they're up to should we take a
quick look at what Pfizer says sure uh
so you can you can
uh video got released on Wednesday
January 25th the project Veritas video
and then at 8 pm yet last night on
Friday 8 pm on Friday uh sort of classic
move there for a moment of release oh
it's called
um it's called taking out the trash
are you even plugged in I I am but you
know the cat's sitting on the cord and
all this so
um I'm plugged in
um so yeah it's called taking out the
trash taking out the trash report
something uh on a Friday because people
aren't paying attention and you don't
want it to uh you you have to report it
but you don't want people to see it yeah
well obviously a lot of people are going
to see this
um but um no one in the mainstream media
I think uh so anyway Pfizer is still
around
so last I checked
Pfizer responds to research claims this
is again Friday January 27th 2023 8 P.M
allegations have recently been made
related to gain of function and directed
Evolution research at Pfizer and the
company would like to set the record
straight would you I don't think so
um but uh actually before we go on
um gain a function versus direct and
evolution because that's one one of the
quotes that I didn't transcribe you
didn't read here is
um uh what's his name Walker says oh you
know we're doing this and the anonymous
date says oh that sounds like gain of
function and Walker says no not really
it's directed Evolution so serial
passage serial passaging is directed
Evolution it's like oh what what kind of
selective pressure can we add or what
kinds of hosts can we serially put this
in this case virus through such that we
can and then select for a particular
outcome that we like uh that is
directed Evolution isn't I think a term
of art but that is it is okay so but you
know it's not over in like basic
Evolution space but in you know yeah I
think I think I got the distinction as
these people see it yeah but but gain of
function is basically a GMO
right like when they're saying gain a
function they mean did we take something
from organism a and put it into organism
B I don't think that's the distinction
okay I think the distinction is so
serial passaging is a mechanism that can
be used for gain a function but it can
also be used to do other things for
example you can attenuate a virus to
make a good vaccine this is one of the
techniques that they use and so by
serially passaging it viruses tend to
evolve towards uh lower virulence and so
the point is you can make a benign
version of a pathogen and that's not
gain of function okay so gain of
function is an outcome
if you have decided in advance what you
want to be gained
regardless of how you get there it could
be gain a function
and serial passaging is a is a method
and directed evolution is not a method
but it's closer to it's it's it's more
mechanistic it's not an outcome I guess
if I read them correctly and frankly I
don't really want to do their homework
for them or they figure out what we you
know in the skeptical public think and
exploit it but I believe the idea is
serial passaging is a technique yeah
serial passaging can be used to enhance
function it can be used to gain a
function there are other techniques that
can be used for gain of function and so
the point is by saying this is a
directed Evolution but not gain a
function what they're saying and frankly
I'm not even going to say that this is
incorrect what they are saying is we are
doing something that was is within
bounds because we're not trying to make
this virus worse our goal was not
to enhance in this case it's a
negatively enhanced virulence or infect
infectiousness
of this virus therefore the research
can't be accurately classified under
gain a function even though you're using
a method that we could have used to do
gain a function research right now if
they are doing what I at the end of this
process and I you know I will say this
fits very well with what we discussed uh
in the first part of of the broadcast
today
we are this is brand new stuff and we
are working our way through it and we
are talking about it over dinner and we
are talking about it with our friends
and we are coming to understand what all
of this means it doesn't mean that the
version that we've got on our minds at
the moment is right I think it's getting
brighter
um but the
uh the
it may actually be correct that this is
not gain of function research in the
sense that we mean it I'm not sure that
that is a defense in light of what I
suspect right most parsimoniously
completes the puzzle of what he said
they were doing so let's go back to
Pfizer's response here I I directed us
away because their first sentence and
Zach you can show my screen again
um the first sentence of their response
from last night is allegations have
recently been made related to gain of
function and directed Evolution research
at Pfizer and the company would like to
set the record straight I'm not going to
read the whole thing although it's not
that long and we'll link to it in the
show notes
they say
in the ongoing development of the Pfizer
bioen Tech covid-19 vaccine Pfizer has
not conducted gain of function or
directed Evolution research
first point
um this P this this unlike the guy on a
date this is written by a team of very
careful uh people and it's been vetted
you just of course by lawyer after
lawyer after lawyer right so in the
ongoing development Pfizer has not
conducted these things they are not
saying that they have never done this
kind of kind of research but in the
ongoing development of this particular
vaccine they it's not even clear in the
ongoing development does that mean it
stopped or it's continuing it's it's not
clear from the way it's from the way
it's written and I think intentionally
vague working with collaborator working
with collaborators we have conducted
research where the original SARS cov2
virus has been used to express the spike
protein from new variants of concern
now when I first read that I was like
why would they even do that and you had
a possible answer that makes sense like
why why would they take the original
virus and use it to express the spike
protein from new variants that are
already they're already out there and I
think I think your answer makes good
sense it's at least it at least fits as
a reason one might do that
if you had data if you had evidence that
had been accumulated from uh original
Wuhan strain virus and you were in the
process of investigating updated
vaccines that used a new code for the
modified Spike protein that has come
about in one of these variants that you
might want on the original background so
that effectively in comparing the two
things your data on this new Spike you
were not also swapping out changes that
had occurred to other parts of the virus
which only works because this vaccine is
so specific to the spike right right
like that's that's the only piece that I
heard missing there right because the
because the virus is only I mean because
the vaccines so-called vaccines are only
using the spike protein they're you
don't need the rest of the virus and
indeed the rest of the virus might
produce noise that could get in the way
of the efficacy of the so-called vaccine
right it would it would be noise that is
counterproductive to your understanding
what the alteration in the spike
sequence had done right
okay uh
this work has undertaken what's a new
variant of concern has been identified
by public health authorities This
research research provides a way for us
to rapidly assess the ability of an
existing vaccine to induce antibodies
that neutralize a newly identified
variant of concern
we then make this data available through
peer-reviewed scientific journals and
use it as one of the steps to determine
whether a vaccine update is required
that's not the most surprising thing in
here but I thought do they I haven't
seen these papers well and they and and
peer review okay they must have the fast
track through peer review and I just I
have not seen these papers right this
strikes me as a description of a
pharmaceutical Utopia in which people
are actually hard at work this is how
science is done right this is how but
here's the thing they describe you know
that we're constantly checking to see
whether a update to the uh the vaccines
that we have deployed is necessary they
have delivered exactly one update right
it's not like so are they telling us
that they didn't spot the need for an
earlier update is that what they're
saying because based on what
based on what that well they were
working at the speed of science
sorry
okay um so here then in the next
paragraph and again like we could spend
hours
trying to understand what this crazy
little document is
but
these two this one phrase and then this
and then the
sentence after it that I've got
highlighted here strike me as
contradictory-ish with a naturally
evolving virus now are they claiming
that SARS cov2 is a naturally evolving
virus is that is is that what we have to
accept now or they just saying or is
this irrelevant
right well it's not even parsable
because do they mean it evolved
naturally or do they mean it is now
evolving naturally right or they like
could they say well you we just mean
anything that has a natural you know
ancestor as opposed to entirely
synthesizing yeah I mean I think so with
a naturally evolving virus it is
important to routinely assess the
activity of an antiviral and it wouldn't
be with a non okay
the sentence feels like it's doing some
important work and we can't figure out
what that work is the next thing I've
got highlighted here in a limited number
of cases when a full virus does not
contain any known gain of function
mutations
again inside this one
such virus may be engineered to enable
the assessment of antiviral activity in
cells
so a limited number of cases
like this one right you're not going to
tell us gain of function mutations
okay a lot of us out here given given
the evidence for lab leak and the serial
passaging and the ferrets and the
humanized mice and the human Airway
passage tissue
uh
feel pretty confident their gain of
function mutations in the SARS Kobe 2
virus in which case this sentence is
irrelevant
or like what job is the sentence doing
here this sentence is highly technical
right the bodies are buried right under
this sentence yes and you can tell
because of the absolutely tortured way
in which it's phrased right I mean for
example just notice such virus in a
number of cases in a limited number of
cases when
how is the sentence different if you
take how would it not be a limited
number of cases
right isn't it inherently a limited
right it's like saying you know when uh
vaccinologist when vaccinology is
performed on Earth
right it does not so I
try to Stillman that part sure
um
sometimes when a full virus does not
contain any known gain of function
mutations we might do some of this uh
fancy engineering behind the scenes but
not always
we've got some subset of viruses that
we're doing stuff on and in some of the
cases within that subset we do this
additional thing so should we expect a
shell game later on where the point is
oh you didn't ask about those cases
right is that what's going to happen
well we didn't say which limited enough
like which limited which number would
tell us which number case you want to
know about and we'll uh we'll let you
see those files yeah um so anyway
there's something very odd about about
this sentence yes um I do think I
understand what they want us to infer
okay which is that when
they know that they have to stay one
side of the line about
enhancing function and so they're
telling us in cases where that's not a
risk because the thing that we're using
is a source doesn't contain them we may
do this other thing
um that allows us to uh
etc etc so anyway
this is of course
uh I've now forgotten who coined this
phrase
this is a non-denial denial
oh right yeah yeah it's a denial in form
but it doesn't really deny what uh what
Jordan uh Walker said right
um so anyway it's about something else
it's about establishing a narrative
about what they do the but I mean
clearly you didn't read the last
sentence of their statement
remind me fact-based information rooted
in sound science is vitally important to
overcoming the covid-19 pandemic and
Pfizer remains committed to transparency
in helping alleviate the devastating
burden of this disease they are
increasingly transparent
um maybe I just feel like what you said
is runs exactly counter to that final
sentence in their statements it's not
odd that they've contradicted themselves
when has that happened in the last three
years right
um all right so let us talk I think that
I think the right order in order for
this to make sense to people is to talk
a little bit about the second video that
project Veritas released what it might
imply and then for me to tell you at the
end of all of this including Pfizer's
non-denial denial what it is that I
think might explain this yeah okay yeah
so anyway we've talked about it right
you're not you're not revealing I'm not
revealing it to you but um
so let's talk about the uh the second
video and the um
yeah so the second let me set it up sure
I mean I don't have any any quotes from
it I ran time
um I have I have the gist presumably
most of our audience will have seen it
and again I think it's actually
fascinating that YouTube struck this
video and struck project veritas's
Channel yeah I don't know if they struck
the second video presumably but maybe I
don't know it's possible the strike
happened before that video was released
yeah in any case the question is you
know this is obviously a matter of
global importance the fact that Pfizer
has responded in the tortured uh way
that it has says it's a completely uh
responsible thing to be talking about
what is the meaning of what Pfizer said
versus what their executive said what
are we to understand that they are
actually doing and how okay should we be
with it is it within the law right is it
tolerable
um but anyway in the second video what
we see is the fact that uh Jordan Walker
has been
lured into saying things on the record
that he did not know were on the record
he thought he was on a date
um he says things about his work and
they reveal
um uh James O'Keefe comes out and
replaces the CEO and the head guy the
project house comes in and tries to
interview him about what he said and I
think it is fair to say you tell me if
I've got the description uh off my
language my notes say uh he freaks the
out he freaks the out yes I
was going to find euphemisms for
freaking the out but um that is
what what happens yeah I mean as you
would
foreign
if you would just if you had just said
those things
while you were trying to get laid and
instead it turns out it was for the
whole world
um I'm not I'm not excusing him but the
fact that he doesn't take it calmly no
no not surprised I'm not surprised that
his blood pressure goes through the roof
obviously he shouldn't have said the
things that he said for professional
reasons obviously the things he is
reporting are disturbing in and of
themselves as he says as he's telling uh
his date these things he keeps saying
you're not going to say anything don't
tell me I promise right
um so it's not surprising that he that
his mind is going a mile a minute
um however his reaction is very very
tough I think okay
um
so we've I think we have not mentioned
because so far it has not been relevant
um he is black
it is implied by what we have said that
he is gay he is on a gay date
um
his reaction
involves uh a tremendous amount of drama
and his trying out various different
approaches to somehow uh
rewrite the history of what's happened
here and he says he calls the police and
he says to them well he calls the police
before the police arrive he no he says
to them on the phone oh on the phone we
don't see they never see him in person I
think before he calls the police he says
that he was lying in fact it's his first
uh instinct is to say I was lying and
that doesn't change O'Keefe's approach
then he says you're in trouble you
screwed up like right but then on the
phone with the police the thing that is
maybe the most remarkable is he says I'm
surrounded by five white men
no one has mentioned race at all it's
true I mean we don't we can't see all of
them but presumably he's correctly
identified their race
it is clearly irrelevant to what has
happened but it is a very interesting
phenomenon to have emerged oh hold on we
haven't so if you haven't seen they're
in a restaurant yeah and so the
restaurant staff are there and um also
uh Walker
somehow blocks the door or locks the
door it's a little bit unclear exactly
who did it what happened
um but the restaurant staff want
everyone to get out of there because
this isn't good for business and Walker
insists that you know the five white men
of which he is supposedly scared or
something according to what he says to
the police they must stay there they
it's absolutely mandated that they stay
there right and in fact he says that uh
so he's not surrounding they are making
him unsafe yeah he says that okay so
when I saw that I thought wait a minute
maybe this is a You know despite the
fact that the biology that he reports
doesn't make any sense maybe this is a
big story but it's not the story that
project Veritas thinks it has maybe this
is a story of incompetence and diversity
equity and inclusion because the point
is on the one hand he has said lots of
biological things that don't add up okay
and on the other hand he's in this
reasonably High position at Pfizer
responsible in some way for something
about mRNA the exact topic on which he's
saying things that don't add up
um
and then his first
Instinct upon being caught having said
these things about his work environment
is this is about race and I feel unsafe
which he's obviously not his first
instinct is I was lying
but that doesn't immediately uh dissolve
the situation and so he makes it about
race he talks about not feeling safe he
goes there he goes the place that
everyone is being encouraged to go now
and often will completely shut down a
conversation or a situation right so one
possibility here is as those who are in
corporate environments presently know
there is all of this uh energy around
ESG ESG being
environment social and governance right
these supposed scores that allow you to
evaluate how honorable a corporation is
it's a total nightmare and a debacle and
it's going to make the world much worse
much faster but nonetheless that's the
claim about what these ESG scores are
about
in a world where corporations are
minding their ESG scores and uh in which
uh there are woke mobs everywhere uh
weaponizing HR departments and all of
these things there are going to be lots
of people hired who are not qualified to
do the thing for which they are hired in
order to placate the mob with respect to
demographics right I don't know if this
is the moment I've got a couple of
pieces of evidence that that is exactly
going on at Pfizer okay not with regard
to ESG but with regard to the EI
diversity Equity inclusion so in an
undated post on Pfizer's site it has to
be from the second half of 2021 or later
they celebrate their new hire uh one ram
says Jean Louis who I may be
mispronouncing his name it's their new
hire to lead the diversity Equity
inclusion office he's the global chief
he says Jean Louis says I feel as if
I've joined an organization that has the
mentality and philosophy that nothing is
impossible when we apply that same
urgency and attention to the area of
diversity equity and inclusion the
possibilities are endless said Jean
Louis who started the job in July 2021.
Equity has been one of our core values
for a number of years now it wasn't
reactionary it wasn't an impulsive
response to the racial crisis that
climaxed in 2020.
then he talks a little bit about having
grown up in Brooklyn his family's from
Haiti and later in the same post they
quote physics chairman and CEO Albert
borla quote
Pfizer's commitment to equity is
all-encompassing and defines who we are
as a company it's about ensuring every
person is seen heard and cared for
reducing Health Care disparities and
making sure that everyone has an
opportunity to express themselves and
bring their authentic selves into the
workplace it's also about holding our
leaders accountable for living these
behaviors every day said borla we are
taking a data-driven approach to our
Equity commitments and I am thrilled
that Ram Has Come Aboard to lead these
efforts
a data-driven approach to equity
commitments
is a Horseman of the Apocalypse phrase
if ever I've heard one so data driven is
itself a disaster and it is a it for me
it's become a tell of like if you're a
scientist like I'm all data driven like
I don't think you know what science is
go back to the drawing board and bring
me a hypothesis but a data-driven
approach to our Equity commitments
they're just counting up demographic
markers right that's what that means
they're just counting them up and saying
oh we don't have enough of this type go
out and find me some of that type and
bring them in it's insane right so
you've got evidence from inside of
Pfizer that they're counting demographic
markers which implies the existence of a
certain number of positions in which the
person in that position isn't expected
to be competent or doing anything it
would be helpful I guess but the the
fact is you've then got this guy who
doesn't really seem to fit the
seriousness of the position that he
appears to be in and what he reports
when he's talking about his professional
life doesn't add up biologically right
now what are the chances that his there
is something odd about his work history
right this is a urologist who spent one
year at a hospital right this is and he
was at a consulting firm right and then
he comes in through the door of a you
know of a consulting firm uh into Pfizer
and so anyway who knows what that all
means but it is possible there but we've
seen as will have maybe all
but presumably most of our audience have
seen examples
among you know friends of people we know
and and colleagues and acquaintances of
people being Advanced not because of
what they know how to do
but because of what they look like or
where they come from and in fact they
are advanced in you know in lieu of
other people who actually have skills
being Advanced and and this is if we've
been talking about this for a very long
we've been talking about this for a very
long time now the most tragic thing
about it is that when you have something
like Pfizer counting people of different
races as a matter of checking off some
boxes what that does is it invites in
people who are using that mechanism to
rise to the exclusion of people who
might meet those same demographic
criteria who are highly qualified in
other words this is a system that's
going to play towards the people who are
inclined to game it and here you have
somebody who does seem like they are
gaming the system right it just doesn't
seem scientifically it doesn't seem
scientifically competent he seems
frankly
at best completely amoral he is
reporting with Glee on the
enhancing of viruses by his company in a
way that the public would obviously be
upset about if they knew and he talks
about the risks of one of these things
getting out risks that are obviously
real and profound he is not speaking
with any seriousness about this so
anyway this is this is a lightweight and
this lightweight is in a position that
doesn't make sense for a lightweight in
the corporation there and then his first
instinct upon being caught having said
things he shouldn't have is to resort to
these are white men I feel unsafe so the
point is this does seem like somebody
who games systems in this point he's
trying to use the police to get himself
out of having said stuff that was
irresponsible right he wants the fact
that the police come in and they see
white men challenging a black man to to
be the sum total of the story he's
trying to create an architecture to
escape responsibility for what he said
so
all right now we've got two
questions on the table it is possible
that he is incompetently reporting
uh about biology taking place inside of
Pfizer in a way that is informative in
some fashion but hard to parse because
it doesn't make sense that's the story
that project Veritas thinks it has then
there's another possible story in which
this is really incompetence Rising
through all of the mechanisms of society
through diversity equity and inclusion
and isn't it a little bit ironic that
it's even you know wrecking corrupt
organizations like Pfizer right that it
comes for everyone right that that
that's comedy right there but here's the
question
after I keep thinking about everything I
heard him say and then the incredible
spectacle of what happens when he's
revealed
I think it's both stories
I think that this is a lightweight and
incompetent person reporting something
he did not understand that is of
consequence that's my best guess and so
here I want to fill in what I think is
most likely to explain this mysterious
experiment in which serial passaging is
taking place in monkeys in a way that
does not appear to serve Pfizer's
interest
here's the missing element
you vaccinate the monkeys
if you vaccinate the monkeys
and then you serially passage the virus
through them you detect the leak in your
vaccine and you do see something like
the next variant coming right in other
words he never says you vaccinate the
monkeys and that's why this is such a
head scratcher but if you did vaccinate
the monkeys and then you serially
passage this vaccine what you will get
is an environment in which they
seriously passage the virus the virus
through the through the monkeys the
virus will find the leak and it will
evolve to exploit it and it will become
the the vaccine will be less and less
effective which if the vaccine works on
that I mean it oh the vaccine will work
that's the beauty of the MRNA technology
isn't it
right if you can infect the monkeys and
you deliver this mRNA so-called yeah if
they're infectable with the virus
they're yes right yeah I mean it is look
it's an mRNA transcript their ribosomes
will transcribe it as well as ours so
okay the vaccine works in the monkeys
you
um
serially passage it the virus defeats
the vaccine because of course it will
which is what you and I have been saying
forever right right this is too narrow a
vaccine so you can predict the vaccine
will fail
the virus will evolve to overcome it and
what I think Jordan Walker is saying is
and then we will know the next vaccine
we need way ahead of time and so the
point is we can accelerate our
development cycle by exploiting the
defects in our own vaccine and
delivering supposedly Curative vaccines
that will also leak we can just get
ahead of this thing right that would
make a lot of sense and frankly it
sounds a hell of a lot like Pharma right
Pharma is
um rather profoundly indifferent to the
side effects of its own treatment why in
part because those will require other
drugs and so to the extent that it makes
you sicker by giving you something that
cures something you've got or helps you
know the point is that we got a drug for
that too so you know it's we've got an
app for that Pharma version it's
interesting I wonder
um you know
it would be interesting to see the whole
video because obviously project Veritas
has edited it to provide the most
interesting Parts but the quote that I
have here is him saying the way it would
work is we would put this virus in these
monkeys and then we successfully cause
them to keep infecting each other when
we collect serial samples from them and
Etc et cetera but these monkeys could
just be like we got these monkeys or or
he could be referring to I've just been
talking about these monkeys that were
vaccinating yes like he he could have
actually said that piece and we just
don't know that's true it'd be
interesting it's at least you know if
it's not in the video it doesn't tell us
anything if it is in the video it helps
us test this hypothesis that that's
actually what he's
um referring to I did want to point out
a couple things yeah right so we've got
a hypothesis on the table about what he
might actually have meant that he's
misreported this and that the reason it
doesn't make any sense is because he
forgot an element where he didn't
understand that that element was
required he just knew that there was
some plan to get ahead business-wise by
creating variants that absent this
wouldn't help yep you will create
variants maybe but it won't be useful in
this case they'll be absolutely useful
because basically you're using the virus
to find your leak right how will a virus
respond when there's when the when the
immunity is non-sterilizing okay a
couple things
one
if this is what Pfizer is doing
then it validates the idea which was
Central to the contentious battles we
were in
uh when the variance problem first
emerged about whether or not a trial was
enough to cause the emergence of
variance right because the challenge
that many people offered to us was that
it can't be that the vaccines the
so-called vaccines are triggering the
emergence of variance because the
variants show up too early the variants
however show up in places where trials
were held
and so the point is well look if you can
do this in a you know how many monkeys
do they have
yeah let's say it's a thousand that'd be
a lot of monkeys right
um but you know if a trial on a small
number of monkeys is enough to give them
information on variants
then the point is well it doesn't take
very many so that would sound like a
trial so anyway that's one connection
here
the other one is strange
do you remember you and I never delved
very deeply because it's not our area of
specialty you know you and I are not
Gene jocks
um but remember Chris Martinson went
after the question of why is Omicron so
weird
that question has never been answered
yeah okay Omicron it's it's it seems
novel
not only novel it seems to be
it seems that it was frozen in time
that it is not descended from anything
that was circulating at the time that it
emerged right right yep that's right and
the other thing that was weird about it
was that it had a incredible ratio of
non-synonymous mutations to synonymous
mutations
right so
something had
it was like a hundred times the other
written by non-synonymous mutations to
Sonos mutations
um the mutations that were recorded in
this new creature Omicron uh were
heavily biased in the direction of
mutations that actually changed the
protein sequence
so with with the ratio of mutations
within Omicron was biased okay I thought
okay by a hundred times the others so
and what's the I can't I'm trying to
think of like what what's the math on
the usual ratio the usual ratio in the
other variance was less than one percent
okay and it was like eighty percent okay
in Omicron so
what does that even mean what is Omicron
where did it come from and you know
there are various possibilities right
you and I talked about the possibility
that it was a white hat attempt to
vaccinate the world to shut down the
pandemic that somebody tried to take
this out of the hands of the incompetent
people who had driven it in the first
place that was one possibility another
possibility
um was that
um
I mean it's possible it was circulating
in some way that we couldn't see it
though that would be very weird given
how contagious the thing was right it's
possible that we just didn't detect it
because it was far enough off that the
PCR test didn't uh register it but
another possibility is that somebody was
playing games like
maybe Jordan Walker is telling us we're
going on at Pfizer
and they lost their vaccine I mean they
lost their their test environment right
so they lost it into the world they lost
it into the world which if you think
about it
if his experiment that one he's
describing is
just fixed so it makes sense in the way
I'm suggesting it would have to be right
if they vaccinated the monkeys and then
they serially passaged this thing right
it's actually very similar to the
attenuation program that you would use
to generate a real vaccine
if you weren't so hell-bent on doing
this with mRNA right you would maybe
serially passage your virus to get a
virus that wasn't so virulent yep right
and
this could be an intermediate right that
got out they were planning to release a
booster an mRNA booster and maybe I
don't know so anyway I don't want to go
too far down that road I'm not saying I
think this happened I'm saying it
belongs on the list of possibilities
because the anomalies of Omicron
are profound they have never been
explained the experiment that seems to
be described by Jordan Walker doesn't
make sense in and of itself but there
might be an experiment that he heard
about and didn't completely understand
that would make sense oh it didn't
completely describe right
um so anyway I
it's certainly a fascinating story
yeah and and it brings together just to
just to wrap it up it brings together
these you know these these two domains
about which we spend a lot of time
talking right
the the
corruption and decay of actual science
uh and you know science-ish domains
which includes like public health and um
and public health organizations like The
Who and the CDC Federal granting
agencies like NSF and NIH uh and Pharma
right
um such that so much of the science
being done and of course in Academia as
well uh is just either
inexplicably badly designed such that it
could not possibly reveal uh what it's
supposed to reveal
or the people doing it are so
misunderstanding what complex systems
are and how many things that they are
messing with by changing they're
claiming one variable and often they'll
be changing lots of them uh that there's
no there's no chance of success so we've
got like that space
which
many people who can see
the other space the the risks of Dei of
of woke of the woke ideology
supplanting merit-based advancement and
understanding in the world many people
who can see that other thing the the
woke ideology thing
have not been willing to say
maybe maybe it's going to affect science
and also what happens if the two of them
come together and it's and and you said
this I don't know 10 15 minutes ago but
like this this is a story where they
appear to come together you've got you
know the failure of science-ish domains
as a result of greed and Corruption and
careerism and all of these things that
we talk about all the time with the you
know Ascent of it appears someone and
presumably someone's lots of someone's
uh through the ranks making decisions
that affect the entire planet
who don't appear to have the skills the
understanding necessary to even be able
to describe it to a lay person
how is it that those are the people who
are making decisions on behalf of all of
us and what happens when that process
you know as you and I have been warning
interrupts all functional systems yeah
right you know we are we are playing
with the fate of the world here and the
bridges don't fall down right away the
airplanes don't fall out of the sky
right away but we're we're working on
Legacy competence and we are eroding the
competence of the people who are
actually needing to manage the new stuff
as it arises and
um it you know disaster it's not even
coming it's here bigger and bigger
disasters are are going to happen
um as a result of this
actually there's one more thing that may
be in this I mean this does come sort of
Full Circle to what we're talking about
with regard to to Scott Adams and like
you know how do you do it like how do
you end up predicting correctly time and
time again and one other thing that is
true is that we have because of because
of the training that we had in what is
broadly referred to as Skin Out biology
so there's lots of ways to split up sort
of the study of life on Earth uh but one
of them is sort of is it at the level of
smaller than an organism's skin in
biology or at the level of an organism
or larger skin out biology and we used
to joke with our other skinout biology
friends or their evolutionary biology
friends but not without truth to it that
the skin in biologists like to talk
about well yeah I work on like the
molecular Pathways of such and such in
Mongolian gerbils and then they'd show a
picture of Mongolian gerbil because
everyone loves to see a cute and fuzzy
mammal right and you know the joke was
yeah but if they literally stumbled
across among land durable on the street
they wouldn't know it right like they
wouldn't know it if it dropped on their
head be like oh my God it's a terrible
thing like they wouldn't know it was
their supposed study animal and this is
about the the reductionism and the you
know data-driveness and the tech happy
approach
to science that so many people are
engaging in now because uh you know this
isn't relevant so much to to the
question of SARS Kobe 2 and virus and
and vaccine development but
if you can go outside and see the thing
uh in its you know in its habitat that
is going to give you a lot more insight
than sitting around thinking about it
from your armchair right and whenever
you can see the thing that you are
supposedly studying in the context in
which it evolved you are going to gain
more insight and you are going to be
much less likely to engage in these Tech
heavy
um overly simplistic overly reductionist
Solutions yeah I mean in some sense uh
you at least need to know what your
creature what problem your creature is a
solution to right before you're going to
be really good at thinking about it yes
I did want to add one other thing though
when I first as I alluded at the
beginning of this discussion when I
first ran into this story I was really
alarmed and I was really alarmed because
of the nonsense biology that Jordan
Walker was reporting
and that many dissident voices who are
have been tremendously important in
um pursuing the various anomalies that
have happened during the pandemic uh
weren't talking about the absurdity of
the biology that was being described
my guess
and so I I did worry that this could be
a trap that there's so many hundreds of
billions of dollars at stake
um that a sophisticated trap that caused
all of the people who have successfully
you know survived the onslaught of
Slanders in order to report to the world
what is actually going on and translated
into English so people could understand
what was happening that this was a great
danger if he was reporting gobbledygook
from inside of Pfizer
and people were embracing it too easily
without thinking about the biology
that's obviously a big Hazard and so
there's a question about whether this is
even
real or whether somebody had fed project
Veritas nonsense which
that's never a zero possibility in an
environment so that's discharged on
which so much rest
I am much less concerned about that now
having seen both the reaction of Jordan
Walker to being caught right I think
that was authentic it looked authentic
and it does hint at this larger story
and there is a relatively small
alteration to what he said that then
makes the rest of it sensible enough
right so you know the parsimony
has been restored to this and I'm less
concerned that it could be some kind of
trap but I will say that does then
cause me to want to give the other
dissidents uh a caution
because what I think they must have done
is in their minds connected dots that
hadn't been connected in the video
right they assumed an experiment that
would make sense in place of the
experiment that was described that
wouldn't make sense right and so that
does create a vulnerability I think for
sure on my first watch that's what I did
so
um
I I think it's dangerous right it does
open the possibility of somebody uh
ensnaring the uh the world of Skeptics
well I mean and you know there's there's
all these terms that maybe terms of art
but are used differently by different
people so you know even just the ones we
talked about here gain of function
serial passaging uh directed Evolution
right
um you know the the distinction there
there is I think we arrived at a
relatively clear taxonomy of distinction
between these things but uh it's not at
all clear to me that that is either
those are either stable definitions or
the ones that are being used by uh
people in you know meetings advisor it
does make me want to go back to Rand
Paul's interaction with Tony fauci
you know where he's saying uh that we do
not do gain of function research and
it's pretty obvious that any normal
parsing of the language uh would tell
you that they do it's it's clintonian
right I mean it's it depends on what the
definition of is is we're back there we
are back there on the other hand the
point is okay give me all of the
definitions in this quadrant of the
glossary so we can talk about what you
are and aren't doing and why you feel
entitled right so anyway
um all of this is to say I think
um I think this isn't the Trap that's
not a zero possibility but it's a lower
possibility than I initially feared but
it does suggest that we should all be
more careful and we should all be
talking to each other more and sooner
right leaping to conclusions about
what's being described you know before
we've had a chance to discuss it as a
mistake and it's one that's induced by
um by social media
because the idea is oh my God you know
project Veritas has just released this
thing I'm going to be expected to say
something on it and so anyway that
pressure to talk is making people un
careful and uh
that's
um
that's a problem
all right I think we're done I think so
too all right
so we are going to be back here again
next week and we're going to be back
here again in 50 minutes as well to
answer your questions you can ask them
at darkhorsesmissions.com
and consider joining us tomorrow at 9 00
a.m Pacific we're doing our two hour
private q a two hours earlier than we
usually do this month uh that'll be
tomorrow the questions are in they're
great that's a small enough group that
we are able to interact with the chat uh
and uh and then we do leave that up also
for people
on my patreon uh we
yeah lots more to say always but uh
we're very very glad to have you our
audience we get great Communications and
sometimes gifts from from all you in
fact there's a book right there that
came in for you yeah I noticed that
beautiful and uh until we see you next
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
foreign